what is candlestow candles tau is a
correlation coefficient and this does a
measure of the relationship between two
variables but what is the difference
between Pearson correlation and candle's
rank correlation in contrast to Pearson
correlation candle's rank correlation is
a non-parametric test procedure thus for
the calculation of candlest Tau the data
need not to be normally distributed and
the two variables need only have ordinal
scale levels exactly the same is true
for the Spearman rank correlation right
that's right candlestow is very similar
to spearman's rank correlation
coefficient however candles Tau should
be preferred over spearman's correlation
if very few data with many ranked ties
are available but how is candle style
calculated we can calculate candlest Tau
with this formula where C is the number
of concordant pairs and D is the number
of discordant pairs what are concordant
and discordant pairs we will now go
through this with a simple example
suppose two doctors are asked to rank
six patients according to their physical
health one of the doctors is now defined
as a reference and the patients are
sorted from 1 to 6. now the sorted ranks
are matched with the ranks of the other
doctor EG the patient who is in third
place with a reference Doctor Is In
fourth place with the other doctor now
using candles Tau we want to know if
there is a correlation between the two
ratings for the correlation of candles
Tau we only need these ranks we now look
at each individual Rank and note whether
the values below are smaller or greater
than itself
so we start at the first rank three one
is smaller than three so gets a minus
four is greater so gets a plus two is
smaller so it gets a minus six is
greater so gets a plus and five is also
greater so it also gets a plus now we do
the same for one here of course each
subsequent rank is greater than one so
we have a plus everywhere at rank four
two is smaller and six and five are
greater now we do this for rank two and
rank six then we can easily calculate
the number of concordant and discordant
pairs we get the number of concordant
pairs by counting all the Plus in our
example we have 11 plus in total we get
the number of discordant pairs by
counting all the minus in our example we
have a total of four minus C is that 11
and D is 4. candle's Tau now is 11 minus
4 divided by eleven plus four and we get
a candle style of
0.47 we get an alternative formula for
candle style here with s is C minus D
therefore 7 n is the number of cases ie6
if we insert everything we also get 7
divided by 15. just like the Pearson
correlation coefficient R candles Tau
also varies between
-1 and 1 with the help of the
coefficient we can now determine two
things number one how strong the
correlation is and number two in which
direction the correlation goes the
strength of the correlation can be read
in a table if we have a coefficient
between
-1 and less than zero there is a
negative correlation thus a negative
correlation between the variables if we
have a coefficient between greater than
zero and one there is a positive
correlation that is a positive
relationship between the two variables
if the result is zero we have no
correlation often however starting from
a sample we want to test a hypothesis
about the population we calculated the
correlation coefficient from the sample
data now we can test if the correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero thus the null hypothesis is
the correlation coefficient tau is equal
to zero there is no relationship and the
alternative hypothesis is the
correlation coefficient tau is n equal
to zero there is a relationship now we
want to know if the correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero you can analyze this either by
hand or with a software like data tab
for the calculation by hand we can use
the set distribution as an approximation
however for this we should at least have
40 cases so the six cases from our
example are actually too few we get a
set value with this formula here we have
Tau and N is the number of cases and now
I will show you how to calculate
Campbell's Tau online with data tab to
do this simply copy your own data into
this table and click on correlation then
you select the desired variables for
which you want to calculate candle style
now all you have to do is click here on
candles Tau and you're done here you can
see the results we also get a candlest
Tau of 0.47 if you're not sure how to
interpret the results just click on
summary inverts a candle style
correlation analysis was performed to
determine if there is a relationship
between variables A and B There is a
medium positive relationship between
variables A and B with r equal to
0.47 thus there is the mean positive
correlation in the sample between A and
B the result of candle style correlation
analysis showed that there was no
significant relationship between A and B
this is because the calculated p-value
of
0.188 is greater than the significance
level of 0.05 thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed the video